BUT RIGHT NOW IT IS TIME TO PLAY
HAL-O-WHAT THE --
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
HALLOWEEN IS NIGH UPON US,
BUT FOR A CERTAIN BREED OF
BASEMENT DWELLING WEIRDOES ON
YOUTUBE EVERY DAY IS AN EXCUSE
TO DRESS UP IN A HOMEMADE
COSTUME.
THAT'S NOT WEIRD.
STOP IT.
I AM GOING TO SHOW YOU A DRESSED
UP CREEP ON YOUTUBE AND FOR
250-POINT YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO GIVE ME THEIR NEW
CATCHPRHASE.
FIRST ONE: THIS SPONGEBOB I
ASSUME HE'S NOT WEARING PANTS.
>> F IS FOR FRIENDS.
U IS FOR YOU AND ME.
N IS FOR ANYWHERE UNDER THE SEA.
>> Chris: KEVIN.
>> HEY, KIDS, USE MY FACE AS A
TOILET.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JAY.
>> HEY, KIDS, I WANT YOU TO
TOUCH ME UNDER MY SEA.
>> Chris: YES POINTS. GOOD.
NEXT ONE, THIS TERRIFYING
GOURMET.
>> HELLO, EVERYONE.
I AM COMING TO YOU WITH A CANDY
REVIEW.
OH, IT SMELLS LIKE STINKY
PARMESAN CHEESE, YOU KNOW, LIKE
STINKY FART CHEESE YOU PUT ON
YOUR PIZZA.
>> Chris: KEVIN.
>> UNBOY ROSEANNE.
>> Chris: WHAT AN AMAZING
MATCH-UP.
POINTS.
STEVE.
>> DOES THIS SMELL LIKE
CHLOROFORM TO YOU?
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS LOVER OF EXPLODING FRUIT.
>> OH!
>> THAT QUICKLY?
>> Chris: THAT IS ONE OF THE
MOST AMAZING THINGS I HAVE EVER
SEEN IN MY LIFE.
YES, KEVIN.
>> BANANA BUKAKES FOR EVERYONE!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: JAY.
>> THIS IS MY ELABORATE SCHEME
TO CATCH A MONKEY AND BLOW IT
UP!
>> Chris: POINTS.
POINTS.